[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et alain grappe nous a rejoint commenter
les voilà on est ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes conseiller
départemental dont le contour de
capillaires on aime bien sûr alsace20 se
balader dans les cantons voire un petit
peu le travail qui est fait on a été
très étonné de découvrir le vo2 non pas
parce que on le connaissait pas il est
formidable mais cette patrouille dans
les vignes c'est une patrouille de la
brigade verte du haut-rhin qu'on a eu le
loisir de suivre l'ouverture est
également d'un endroit qui est magique
c'est les dominicains de guebwiller
rencontre avec adrien labit
patrouillent dans les vignes au dessus
de soultz seigneur et jason sont deux
des 23 fier destrier de la brigade verte
un corps de garde champêtre veillant sur
les territoires duo a
créé à la fin des années 80 cette unité
est unique en france financé par le
département et les communes adhérentes
le syndicat mixte des gardes champêtres
intercommunaux rempli de nombreuses
missions au service des collectivités
ils sont encore assiégées par les
communes donc 3 122 communes ont
souscrit pour
377 communes au total dans le haut rhin
il y a également deux communes du bas
rhin qui adhèrent à ce groupement sous
la police du maire il veille à la
quiétude évidemment au niveau forestier
au niveau rural au niveau
environnemental en priorité mais c'est
également la police du maire dans le
cadre de toutes les infractions
les infractions à la au stationnement
les déchets les ordures
le sionneau également de d'animaux
sauvages ou pas sauvage qu'il faudrait
qu'il faut évidemment ramené à l'espagne
la brigade est aussi engagé dans la
traque de l'ennemi public numéro 1 du
département le moustique tigre petites
bêtes responsable de la transmission de
la dengue et du chikungunya
alors le moustique tigre effectivement
c'est une sas est une compétence
principale du département et donc nous
nous pilotons et nous finançons pour
cette opération et donc c'est quoi c'est
la prévention suivi des larves la la
gestion si on hélicoptère puisque là on
peut utiliser des produits
phytosanitaires en hélicoptère pour
éviter la propagation de ces larves donc
on devait donc on a quelqu'un qui veille
tout le temps et qui qui est au fait des
populations
guebwiller en fin d'après midi ça
s'agite dans les jardins de l'ancien
couvent ce soir les dominicains lancent
leur saison culturelle 2016 2017 au menu
expo musique et vidéo mapping mais qui
sont ces dominique a alors les dominique
a est issu d'une histoire qui date du
14ème siècle à 1 qu atre pour religieuse
ici et qui a été transformée dans le
culturel entre temps et qui oeuvre
depuis très longtemps dans la culture et
surtout dans la musique qui baigne dans
la musique j'ai envie de dire donc un
bel écrin pour et villers mais aussi
pour le département puisque le
département en est propriétaire depuis
de nombreuses années et continue à faire
perdurer ce site
centre culturel de rencontre les
dominicains sont là pour faire se
télescoper des artistes d'horizons
divers dans une explosion créative mais
aussi pour provoquer la rencontre des
arts et des publics les dominicains en
tout cas sont aujourd'hui à un lieu où
on se retrouvent pour échanger
simplement mais aussi pour découvrir les
richesses culturelles des autres c'est
un lieu où on peut juste prendre un café
juste échangé mais aussi aller d'un
concert un mapping ou à simplement se
reposer dans le cloître c'est que c'est
un lieu qui permet à aux personnes
empêchées ou en difficulté de venir
d'avoir accès à la culture aux moyennant
1 euro elles sont au rsa ils sont
handicapés ils ont des problématiques et
bien si ça se voit pas on est tous le
celui est vraiment ouvert à toutes et à
tous l'union libre la saison qui s'ouvre
ce soir c'est des concerts des
performances des expos des vidéos et
bien plus encore un mot d'ordre que
l'improbable deviennent énormes à les
mappings dominicain c'est magique c'est
important alain grappe qu'il existe des
lieux comme ça dans vos territoires et
non pas uniquement dans les grands
mozilla c'est effectivement important
pour pour le centre culturel que
représente leur et dominicains mais
c'est important pour la toute la région
puisqu'on nous drainons quand même aux
dominicains certain public qui vient au
delà des frontières en d'allemagne de
suisse donc c'est effectivement très
important nous avons cette chance à sur
le secteur de guebwiller la comcom faire
épouser à peu près le même périmètre que
le quel canton et nous sommes labellisés
au niveau de la comcom pays d'art et
d'histoire ce qui correspond évidemment
communiqué à temps par deux de prime
abord mais également sur tout les
centres de culture que nous avons nous
avons la réponse trauma nous avons
l'abbaye de murbach qui est également
remarquable dans son écrin de verdure et
puis nous avons bien sûr d'autres
d'autres potentiels entre autres des
circuits de randonnée des circuits vtt
bien sûr en hiver la neige avec les
marches taillées vous avez
justement vous en parlez vous êtes dans
un cercle magique puisque à proximité de
chez vous c'est le parc du petit prince
c'est l'écomusée d'alsace vous avez
aussi vous venez de le dire des sites
très touristiques
alors moi ma question est simple c'est
on peut faire travailler vraiment tout
ce monde ensemble c'est primordial parce
que c'est vrai que nous sommes un
secteur qui est certes moins connue que
les secteurs touristiques de de l'alsace
que son strasbourg colmar mais aussi
éric cuir et autres et de fait nous
essayons avec ce potentiel touristique
de faire venir les touristes mais aussi
de les faire rester sur notre secteur et
c'est vrai que le parc du piper du petit
prince qui se développe bien depuis deux
ans la reconversion je crois êter par
médioni winfrey une vraie réussite et
puis bien sûr l'écomusée d'alsace qui
reste quand même un territoire qui est
aussi remarquable et dans le potentiel
reste reste fiable un mot sur
l'actualité on a évidemment en tête les
images dramatiques de ces dernières
inondations le conseil départemental
s'occupe justement de la gestion de look
est ce que vous faites pour éviter ces
catastrophes alors c'est vrai que le
département du haut rhin et qui est
organisée en syndicat mixte sur chaque
cours d'eau pratiquement du département
nous travaillons beaucoup sur ce sujet
et nous investissons aussi beaucoup
depuis des années un jeu j'ai un chiffre
en tête c'est 5 millions de repas par an
l'investis dans les rivières du
département et nous essayons de
fiabiliser de réaliser des bacs de
rétention de façon à éviter que la
concentration de de la pluie qu'on a
nous avons eu encore hier soir un
phénomène assez violent sur le secteur
d'ailleurs de ma commune aux chevilles
je suis où je suis maire c'est vrai que
c'est pas toujours facile de maîtriser
tout ça mais nous y travaillons beaucoup
et c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui
nous prend beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
alors on m'avait présenté les centrales
les minicentrales hydroélectriques que
le département fait installer sur les
cours d'eau s'est fabriqué d'ailleurs en
alsace à guebwiller chez schlumberger et
c'est un dispositif ces mini centrale
qui pourrait s'exporter je pense oui
d'autant plus que j'ai appris il ya à
peine quinze jours que le ministère de
l'environnement a fait un appel à
projets pour développer effectivement ce
genre de microcentrales évidemment c'est
pas beaucoup de mes gars de 2 kilowatts
mais mis bout à bout mais vite voilà
bout c'est vrai que ça en fait beaucoup
et c'est vrai que je suis mme berger qui
était spécial spécialisé dans la machine
textile s'est diversifiée et a fait un
prototype qui a été installé d'ailleurs
sur la lauch qui est à côté de chez nous
et depuis il y en a trois qui ont été
réinstallés dans le secteur du haut rhin
et il y en a d'autres qui peuvent vous
pourront être installés ailleurs en
france pour ceux qui le souhaiteraient
mais il yad'autres cordeau aussi sur le
département comme la fecht comme comme
là j'ai pu j'ai plus de noms en tête
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être un
potentiel intéressant ces deux maux
économiques aussi s et du développement
économique et pour l'entreprise
l'aubergine début l'air c'est important
de se diversifier parce que le textile
mais évidemment ce fait beaucoup dans
les pays maintenant asiatiques mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de friches
industrielles chez nous